cabu calfo pierre bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors on l'a vu en amérique latine la
pandémie gagner encore et toujours du
terrain malheureusement
pourquoi est-ce que la propagation de
l'épidémie ne ralentit pas dans cette
région là alors tout d'abord il ya un
lien flagrant vous l'avait dit entre
néolibéralisme et gestion chaotique de
cette de ce type et des mines
lorsque vous avez dans des pays des
hôpitaux privatiser les délits qui ont
été réduits vous avez malheureusement
des vous avez malheureusement une
gestion catastrophique et des morts
derrière et malheureusement le
l'amérique latine des pays tels que le
chili le brésil où d'autres ou bien
d'autres ont été le laboratoire de ces
politiques néolibérales et aujourd'hui
ils en payent les les
les conséquences et c'est essayer des
populations les premières victimes de
cette de cette situation justement il ya
ces populations il ya ces bidonvilles
cette promiscuité comment ce que le
gouvernement peut aider cette classe qui
est populaire dans les pays
par exemple je pense au brésil est ce
que les établissements de santé sont son
talent mais aussi pour faire face à la
situation alors il est difficile de dire
qu' ils sont armés lorsqu'ils ont été
dépouillés pendant des décennies
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils sont armés
vraisemblablement pas au niveau qu'il
qu'il faudrait maintenant il n'est vrai
il est bien sûr pas trop tard pour
encore mettre tous les moyens
nécessaires etc comme l'a été comme l'a
rappelé au mexique
andrey manuel lopez obrador où il est il
ya une nécessité de trouver bien sûr un
vaccin mais aussi d'autres mais d'autres
médicaments pour pouvoir mettre à
disposition de l'ensemble de la
population et de ne pas faire de
différence entre les différents les
différentes classes sociales car
l'amérique latine ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle souffre c'est à séoul avait
rappelé c'est exactement ça un sixième
des des latino américains qui vivent
dans les bidonvilles sacré bien
évidemment des dégâts justement des
mesures de restrictions ont été mises en
place dans plusieurs pays est ce qu
elles sont respectées par la population
parce qu'on sait que dans certes
certaines personnes dans les bidonvilles
n'ont pas les moyens de rester à la
maison
ils doivent aller travailler alors tout
c'est toujours une vaste question la
question du respect vous savez que déjà
c'est pas une situation naturelle
lorsque vous avez des personnes qui sont
qui sont confinés donc il est plus dur
de ceux de se confiner lorsque vous
n'avez pas de quoi manger que lorsque
vous avez tranquillement vos revenus qui
qui tombent tous les mois donc ccd
situation assez assez paradoxal mais
dans l'ensemble je dirais que les
populations sont sont assez consciente
du risque et ils ont ils ont peur malgré
malgré cela je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
soient toujours aidé par par les
différents gouvernements respectifs
lorsqu'il y à un tel niveau de
corruption lorsque vous avez je disais
tout à l'heure
dead une quantité des décennies de
systèmes de politiques d'austérité
vous êtes bien démuni face à face et 6 à
7 à ces situations et les gens ont
besoin de manger ont besoin
en même temps de ce d'aller d'aller
travailler et c'est toute la difficulté
tout le paradoxe de ceux de cette
situation que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
et justement ça système de santé dans
cette région que ce soit au brésil au
mexique au chili
elles ont exacerbé elles ont encore plus
mis la lumière sur les inégalités qu'il
y avait dans la société tout à fait
alors vous avez plus de dix mille morts
au chili pour un pays qui fait 17
millions d'habitants lorsque vous
vous atteignez récemment plus de cent
mille morts au brésil c'est bien qu'il y
a une c'est bien qu'il ya une raison à
tout ceci lycée je vais dix élèves début
cette politique néolibérale et c'est ce
que je pense qu'on devrait pointer
encore plus deux avec plus de profondeur
politique néolibérale ne ne rime pas
avec protection des populations et on le
voit de plus en plus aujourd'hui et la
population était et et sacs crb et ils
ont bien raison
les différents gouvernements on mise
tout sur un vaccin seulement ce vaccin
et ne sera pas forcément prêts pour
demain
est-ce qu'il sera accessible à la
population et en attendant qu'ils soient
prêts qu est-ce qu est-ce que le
gouvernement va proposer aux populations
pour se protéger alors je l'expert qui
sera accessible en tout cas toute la
population comme l'a affirmé indraise
lopez obrador au mexique après bien
évidemment que d'ici en attente du
vaccin il y à des politiques préventives
qui sont à mettre en place lorsqu'on
constate que les politiques de tests
sont encore payante dans de nombreux
pays y compris ici en france parce qu en
amérique latine
on a de quoi se poser des questions sur
sur la sur la politique sanitaire
préventive et je pense que c'est
c'est l'une des clés des réponses avant
l'arrivée d'un vaccin c'est quelle
prévention au met en place on a parlé de
masque on parle on parle de médicaments
mais médicament curatif mais il ya toute
cette partie préventif qui est qui est
essentiel et malheureusement on pèche
aussi face à cette politique préventive
qui est quasiment inexistante
un clavier quelles frontières merci pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire exécutif national
du parti de gauche et spécialiste de
l'amérique latine merci à vous